all right i'll be the first to say it
we've been covering some cosmic wonder
quite a bit
there's always something to talk about
when spider-man is he's our go-to
spider-man guy
the guy he's spider warrior he's a
spider warren hey you love that he's our
cosmetics we love that spider-worn
spider warren just the other day i
stepped out for a minute it's not even
covered a warren video that's right
so i jumped in i was like you know what
i want warren all for myself today
you did it wanted an intimate chat with
warren and i got it
warren messaged me saying don't you ever
let him do that
all right i'll yes i end that thanks man
never
do that again that's going to make a
difference spider-man
something about a trailer breakdown
break down
the title subscription opening scene
leak
and the trailer is definitely coming
soon it's in the title of this video
all right it should come this month or
next month for sure but let's see what
information is in store
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and it
looks like today we might have
an actual release date for the trailer
for spider-man no way
i love this day
oh my god what to expect from you
perpetual drum roll
two very reputable accounts claiming
that they know when the trailer is going
to come
and the way that they claim they know
the trailer is coming is very legitimate
so the reports of these two people that
we'll dive into in just a bit
combined with the fact that sony has
started to change some of their
background banners on their official
youtube pages and twitter accounts and
the fact that we are starting to get
merchandise for spider-man no way home
all combined
lead us to believe that we do indeed
know when the trailer is coming
you know what's so funny about this sony
doesn't need to release a trailer they
don't they know
everyone is taking care of all the
promotion for them a trailer is supposed
to build hype and anticipation
we've already got that taken care of on
our own
all of us too we don't even need a
trailer that's just so funny about this
we should just do the blumhouse tilt
route and just go all digital no
pna campaign or anything there are so
many
us included are such a big contribution
to this free advertising
videos about what a trailer is coming
inside of the actual movie
we are advertising for the
advertisements it's so funny and not
only
that but it looks like we also may know
what happens in the very beginning
of spider-man no way home which of
course i'll go over as well
also a quick reminder that i will be
announcing the stormbreaker giveaway
winner today
look out for a community post by me or a
video later on in the day today
posting who the winner is so some of you
may have heard
about the instagram account comic book
savage
i got a lot of different dm's about this
instagram account and on this person's
instagram they said my friend who works
at a local movie theater just confirmed
they got the no way home tomorrow it's
100
dropping tuesday coincidentally tuesday
tomorrow is tom holland's birthday so it
seems like i want to get some sleep
accurate
trailer on tom holland's birthday just
like they did for shanghai and the
legends of the 10 rings teaser trailer
they dropped it on
sima leo's birthday who of course is
playing chiang chi
however there are some other reports
that state that yes the theaters do have
the trailer but
it might not be coming on tuesday this
account may have just
heard that yes the theaters have the
trailer and could have assumed
that it is dropping tuesday just because
that's tom holland's birthday right
another reputable account which i'll
talk about in just a bit did say that
the trailer is in
however we might not get it for another
couple of weeks now i did a little bit
of digging
paddington too yeah it looks like
they're actually followed by jamie foxx
himself
so that definitely adds some credibility
but i think what really makes this
report
credible is the fact that this person
isn't the only person reporting this
skyler schuler over at the dis insider a
very
reputable site and podcast has also
confirmed this to be true
he posted a screenshot of a text message
conversation between him and his friend
who works at a theater as well
skyler tweeted this out and said had to
ask a good friend
spider-man no way home he asked his
friend in the theater if they have the
trailer end and he replied with one sec
i gotta pull up the projections for the
week
so it looks like we have it so this is
another concept
fire
reveal their identity dropping and
hopefully this week
if comic book savage is correct it could
be dropping tomorrow however skyler
shuler says that it will most likely
come
in two weeks with the release of peter
rabbit so at this point in time
peter rabbit peter parker trailer is
going to drop
within the next two weeks which is super
exciting and hey hopefully it drops
tomorrow but
this isn't the only news that we got
today we actually have a little bit more
information about the plot of spider-man
no way home
and it seems like we actually have a
description of what to expect from the
teaser trailer i really hope a
he's like it would be cool if he came
out tomorrow because of tom holland's
birthday
it would be cool however
those are early yeah
absolutely what's to say that they're
not gonna have to set a precedent then
and just start only dropping teasers on
people's birthdays it's gonna get out of
hand
i mean yeah it's like just because the
theater's got the trailer
doesn't mean it would cause nothing like
a new movie is coming out tomorrow and
they're like we got
yeah that's how it works i hundred
percent would believe that theaters
already have the trailer and they're
probably
making sure it runs well and all that
that doesn't mean it's going to come out
tomorrow
not necessarily no i mean they they have
to get these things stocked in advance
but if it does get ready for a very
stressed out dark circles looking john
and i tomorrow
what if they just drop it in the
theaters only for like a week
looks like we're sneaking a camera
getting kicked out of cinemark
permanently
so there's a twitter account called no
way home teaser that apparently had a
description of what the teaser trailer
is going to be like they originally
posted the description in spanish but it
has been translated and thank you to my
discord for pointing this out
and this says peter is being sought
after by the fbi for murder
there is a very quick scene of police
breaking into the house with his aunt
there in fear
from what the teaser shows us peter
surrenders and it's very serious what is
going on
almost the entire time peter is living
on the street in what they show in the
trailer but
doctor strange appears the teaser starts
with peter inside some type of
establishment
he takes food and runs away in an alley
it shows a guy from the newspaper
talking about him which i'm presuming is
jj
and then he enters an abandoned shed
then shows his aunt
crying now obviously this translation
isn't a perfect
translation it's not word for word and a
lot is missing from it
but based off of what we do know this
makes a lot of sense because we know
no way home is going to pick up
immediately after the events of
spider-man far from home so that means
peter's identity was just revealed he
was just
framed for murder so it would make sense
that the fbi would be going to his house
where they know he lives
of course doctor strange is widely known
to be in the film so it would make sense
that they would show him
i would not expect tobey maguire or
andrew garfield to make an appearance in
the teaser trailer not in the teaser
alright so there's something i'm not
quite getting here all right because
it's saying
that the fbi i don't believe it
i don't believe this he's with that mate
and then and he surrenders to the fbi
and then he's in an alleyway then he's
homeless the rest of the teaser
yeah they're saying there's an opening
scene not even the teaser right either
way i'm like
wait a minute why would he just be at
home yeah
surrendering himself to the fbi i feel
like he wouldn't necessarily be able to
go home unless it's one of those things
where he went home to like pack really
quick but then why is he packing if he's
going to just surrender to the
i feel like peter parker would know
better yeah especially after
you know being framed and knowing he's
being free yeah like right after this
scene where he's looking at himself and
what is that times square and he's like
no i got to go home
but there's no way to get like peter
parker wouldn't it would know that's uh
that's going to put aunt may in a lot of
danger
yeah i'm kind of interested in the idea
of like oh man peter's been roughing it
out on the streets yeah i don't know how
this whole fbi
like i can imagine peter trying to be a
good guy and be like okay i'll go with
you but at the same time he didn't
he didn't do it so as far as the actual
plot of spider-man no way home is
concerned i've posted
a lot of different plot leaks and rumors
and reports on my channel
really anytime something's popped up
that gives us a little bit of
information about the film i've pretty
much reported
and it looks like based off of all the
information that we've seen out there
we know a pretty decent amount about the
movie based on all of this information
things like toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man returning
from their respective universes into the
mcu
we've heard that the green goblin from
the sam raimi tobey maguire universe is
going to be the main villain of this
film
and of course we know about other
villains returning like jamie foxx's
electro
alfred molina's doc og and more villains
essentially
almost making up the sinister six
although it's unclear on whether or not
they'll call them that in the film so it
looks like we have a lot however it
doesn't look like we know
everything which is awesome because we
want to be surprised obviously
but according to super hero theorist on
twitter
they say there are so many things you
guys don't know yet
i pray that sony somehow finds a way to
tape
up the faucet to avoid leaks because
this film really is
absolutely bonkers based on what i've
seen
for spider-man fans emotions will run
high when the film drops in december
so this movie is looking like it's
actually going to be very
very big obviously if the spider-verse
is involved with the other two
spider-mans but it looks like there's a
lot more in store for us that we don't
know yet which
is awesome but speaking of things that
we might actually
know already some things i've talked
about in the past are how the villains
end up in the main mcu timeline in our
universe from their universe okay well
it looks like we're going to figure that
out in the very beginning
of the film user viewer anon who has
been right about multiple leaks in the
past four previous disney plus shows
has stated what to expect in the
beginning of the film which he says is
act one and here's what he had to say
the sinister six
structurally makes sense and remember
they're dying specifically they're dying
at the hands of
spider-man then we know that they
somehow end up getting taken
from their respective universes and into
the main mcu which has tom holland's
peter parker spider-man and the leak
says that this causes
great guilt in holland's peter and he
ends up doing something stupid
against doctor strange's orders now of
course we know that doctor strange is
going to be peter's
mentor in the film and of course that
makes a lot of sense because the
multiverse is essentially going to be
breaking or bursting into madness why
would it cause an immediate real
concussions are going to be
for peter parker villains coming into
his universe from other universes where
spider-man not him but other spider-man
have caused them to essentially die in
their respective universes
so peter being the good guy that he is
is going to go against doctor strange's
orders which of course is going to be
don't try to fix anything from other
universes let me fix that
but peter is going to go against the
orders and probably do something a
little bit foolish that's going to make
for a pretty good movie and perhaps
that's why doctor strange could bring in
the
other spider-man but fortunately it
looks like we don't have to wait much
longer for the teaser trailer now i do
want to point out
that comic book savage did say the
trailer is going to be on tuesday
however skyler shuler did not
specifically say tuesday
he just said that the theaters have the
trailer so hopefully it does come out on
tuesday but if it doesn't it is
definitely coming very soon
probably this week now it would make
sense to come out
on tom holland's birthday that would be
awesome so let's hope that but don't
give up hope if it doesn't come tuesday
in the meantime don't forget to
subscribe we'll never get a trailer
don't forget to comment below how
excited you are to see the spiderman no
way home trailer don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof i don't know what to believe i
don't either the thing is that even if
we have heard some
actual legitimate descriptions i don't
think they'll
sound as good as they'll look in the
actual movie i think everything will
sound
convoluted and silly until we actually
yes yeah yeah
that's a very good point all right guys
well i'll stress out over the next
what's looking like almost 24 hours
leave your thoughts down below thank you
warren for covering this thank you for
being our go-to spider-man guy subscribe
to warren for all the latest spider-man
updates hit that like button last but
not least
michael linden mikhail here's the deal
we actually have a shout out for you on
a different video yes
that video doesn't go up this week but
there was a sponsor
who's uh taking forever to approve the
damn video yes
and uh i don't know why it's probably
the easiest sponsorship we've ever had
to do in our lives
the least amount of talking points and
yet it's taking forever for it to get an
approval so i was like well there's
something that's coming out of may so i
just wanted to hop on here real quick
mikhail to tell you
you'll get a real proper shout out when
that video is released
tomorrow or wednesday or thursday it's
coming man you'll see it
and you're gonna like it so this is your
temporary shout out in the meantime yeah
man
ooh look at somebody nice this one is
the may deadline for you yeah
stay strong out there michael love you
sending you hugs
james bond october 8th 2021 see you
[Music]
buddy
you